good morning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special that when you
unleash it it will be able to change the
world so to help you on your journey
today's message is take your own path
over to you Peter Dinklage I'm a writer
so I'm kind of curious what type of
scripts do you get coming your way that
you're tired of I mean originality I
know that's a very but without it being
aware that it's or being original a lot
of scripts are trying to be very
original and it they're so self-aware I
think we're living nowadays in a meta
Society and we can't help ourselves than
that and I think a lot of manifest
Lutton and scripts that I read like
their Charlie Kaufman for example he
came into this world and he wrote those
movies and since Charlie people have
tried to be like Charlie's movies you
know they've sort of followed try to
follow that form but it's not their own
it's Charlie's and so sort of follow
your own take your own path right what's
true to you and no one else and then
it'll be wholly original that's what I
look for so I agree that ultimate
success will come from taking in your
own path by you being different if you
look like everybody else and you're
selling the same product the same
service as everybody else you're not
gonna stand out you're not going to
achieve greatness the people who go on
to do amazing things in any field are
the ones who are unique who set the
trends who have their own style and then
everybody else kind of follows that but
then maybe counterculture advice that I
have is often to get to that point you
need to copy people at the beginning I'm
a big believer in modeling and copying
at the start of your journey when you
don't know what you're doing when you're
trying to figure things out
you copy people you copy others you try
things on you see if it fits before you
become a clothing designer making brand
new clothes of your own style you you
buy other people's clothes and you try
them on and you see how it fits and you
start to develop your own style you
develop your own style by trying on
other people's styles and
then be able to modify them and make a
twist singers when they start out a lot
of them start as cover bands right you
you might cover the Beatles or you might
cover Metallica you might cover somebody
else and as you cover those artists you
develop your own style you start to
figure out I like how this person
doesn't I like I want to pull that from
this person that from this person and
then you were able to tweak it for
yourself and so I think if you start off
trying to be wholly original it makes it
really difficult for you ever to really
achieve greatness because you don't know
how things work in the industry and
you're missing out on a lot of learning
opportunities or think of at the
beginning you copy you model you take
things that have worked for other people
that can get you 80% of the way and
really quickly because if you're copying
from somebody else who's achieved a lot
of success that shortcuts your path I
mean you still to do the work but it
gets you there a lot faster then you
trying to figure out everything on your
own
right if you had to figure out a equals
mc-squared on your own you probably know
you'll do it but you can learn it from a
book and then understand how to apply it
so you can learn from the lessons and
mistakes and pass of other people to
help you get some more faster but it
only takes you 80% of the way right if
you copy Mariah Carey the best you're
gonna become at that is just a junior
Mariah Carey if you sound exactly like
her the best you'll be able to get is a
cover band of Mariah Carey I may be
singing on cruise ships and that's a
great career but it's not where you
could be it's not where the ultimate
greatness comes from and so you're
taking these bits from different people
it's why I have this channel it's why I
do these top tens and mentor meets and
all these series is to expose you guys
and myself to new ideas to how different
people operate and maybe spot something
to say that's interesting how that works
for Elon Musk that's really cool
I want to try that and it's beginning
you're just copying Elon you know words
that he's using or thought process or
brainstorm and you're copying something
and it may work for you to a certain
degree and then the magic will come when
you twist it and you figure out okay
that worked for Elon I got to add my own
little special ingredients to it to make
it work for me and so ultimately swil
come when
you are finding your own path when
you're creating your own art but that's
the final 20% to shortcut your path that
first 80
I'd recommend copying modeling studying
learning as much as you can from people
who've come before you so you can
quickly figure out your style what you
like what resonates well with you what
works for you and then add your seeking
ingredient to fight back so the question
of 1880 is I'm curious what have you
learned most from somebody maybe it's
somebody that we profiled on the top 10
video someone on this channel give me
somebody in your family or somebody that
you've met as a mentor what's a lesson
that you learn from somebody else that
you were able to apply to your life to
your business that really had a big
impact on you I'd love to hear your
feedback please leave it down the
comments below I also want to give a
quick shout out to Kaylee and Bradley
thank you guys so much for picking up a
cup of my book your one word and taking
that picture and send it it into me you
guys are great I really appreciate your
support and I hope you enjoyed the book
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love and I'll see you
guys again tomorrow morning for another
shot of vinspresso
now if you're an artist or a filmmaker
or content creator in general do you
feel like you shouldn't even go
mainstream towards TV or towards film or
towards working with a music label or
should you focus on creating it all
yourself because it it still helps a lot
of people who don't know how to do the
online yeah I mean look there's there's
no answer to that question I think that
it's one thing that everybody but the
successful people fail to realize about
any creative industry is that there is
absolutely no defined path there isn't
one so it's about paving your own path
and now for me my path meant mainstream
just didn't work and new media did work
and for other people it's entirely
antithetical to that world where
mainstream is exactly the right place
for them so there is no formula that's
that's right or wrong I'm just much
better versed in my own sure the
trajectory that I found myself and that
includes really running away from the
establishment into whatever the most
forward-thinking space is the idea is
that every pursuit no matter how
glamorous it may seem no matter how
exciting you are it feels to you no
matter how much you feel like you were
born to do it comes with a sandwich and
so the question is not what do I love
the question is what do I love so much
that I don't mind eating the sandwich
that comes along with that thing so for
me in my life writing is the thing that
I love and the sandwich was the 7 years
that I was not getting published and
that I was coming home from my job as a
diner waitress as a bartender as an au
pair as a somebody who worked in flea
markets as a cook and I was coming home
tired and smelling like other people's
french fries and sitting down and doing
my real job which was to write and then
to go to the mailbox the next day and
get another rejection letter and then
say do I still want to do this because
[Laughter]
you know and I did still want to do it
and now even as somebody who makes their
living as a writer there's no end to the
sandwiches it's like oh hello horrible
review in prominent newspaper that's
your sandwich today was you still want
to do this work yeah yeah I still do
still worth it like hello um awful
comment on social media from somebody
who
thinks you're a pile of so much you know
it just has like chosen every possible
way that they can just cannot get it out
of their system fast enough how much
disregard they have for your entire life
yeah still want to do this thing yeah I
still want to do it you know so that's
the question because if the first time
you encountered it should sandwich
you're like well this this isn't worth
it then that's not the thing you're
supposed to be doing yes and there are
plenty of things in life that that I
have run into the sandwich I've been
like so not worth it so not worth it
like this is not I don't want to do this
like whatever the bed alleged benefits
of this thing yes might be no SoulCycle
no you know like I know it's probably
really good for me but I feel like
throwing up right now is too hard um
you'll not be seeing me here again you
know like um and I love my sisters is
SoulCycle I just don't like feeling like
I'm going to throw up when I exercise so
it's not for me you know um and and so
that's the question so if you go into
this thing thinking if I follow my bliss
and I live my dream and I stand in my
truth then everything will be great it
doesn't mean everything will be great
it just means at the end of the day when
you check in with yourself and you go in
the end on the balance is this still
better than not doing it and the answer
is still yeah this thing is still better
than not doing it then you're on the
right path while traditional paths may
seem harder to find that also means that
you may lune learn sooner than most
generations the hard lesson that you
must always make the path for yourself
there is no secret society out there
that will tap you on the shoulder one
night and show you the way because the
true secret is your life will not be
defined by the society that we have left
you to paraphrase Robert bolt Society
has no more idea of what you are than
you do because ultimately it has only
your brains to think with every
generation must define itself and so
make the world that suits itself so
if you must find your own path and we
have left to no easy path then decide
now to choose the hard path that leads
to the life and the world that you want